yeah
[Music]
it's that time again Sony have announced
the PS plus essential offerings for
October 2022. as always you can grab
these games from the first Tuesday of
the month which this time is October the
4th this month we have a brutal fighter
a teeny tiny racer and a matrix inspired
first-person shooter so let's do this we
begin with Injustice 2. this fighting
game may be five years old but it still
holds up superbly well to this day
almost every issue players had with Gods
Among Us has been addressed Injustice 2
is faster than Injustice 1. with better
use of combos more environmental
interactions more super moves unique to
each character and of course it just
looks more impressive an impressive
update is based around managing a meter
to get the edge in battle use a portion
of your bar to become briefly immune to
those annoying people who throw out the
same projectile move over and over again
that meter can be used for far more than
that so be sure to get to know it as
soon as you can to get the most out of
Injustice 2. the story mode campaign
attempts to tell a story about
Superman's fall and becoming a tyrant
but it's a little too depressing if I'm
honest and it becomes a chore rather
than a highlight to play through kinda
like the movies the Multiverse mode is
another highlight as we complete daily
challenges to level up characters and
change their Aesthetics to stand out
from the crowd making your fighter look
how you choose once you unlock that
piece of clothing Injustice 2 received 9
out of 10 reviews across the board from
all major outlets and since then the
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles have been
added to make the roster absolutely
enormous game number two has both PS4
and PS5 versions Hot Wheels Unleashed
another amazing game that you need to
try an arcade racer on a tiny scale that
feels like you're traveling at 100 miles
an hour when in fact you could walk
quicker the tracks weave Under and Over
household items in someone's kitchen
bedroom and living room the more aware
players will find cheeky shortcuts over
countertops and under tables to reduce
the car boss driving towards a
basketball and realizing it's not as big
as a house you're in a toy car it all
adds to the character of Hot Wheels
Unleashed if you ever owned a Hot Wheels
car there's a chance you'll find it in
the game including some huge tie-ins
such as the Delorean from Back to the
Future online sessions support 12
players for some crazy game nights with
friends or there's a split screen mode
for couch Co-op if that's more your
speed and for Creative people there is a
very competent track Creator to do with
whatever you want reviewers tell us we
should play Hot Wheels Unleashed
averaging an 8 out of 10 score and
finally super hot a first person puzzle
shooter not to be confused with the
brilliant VR game of the same Name the
basic premise is simple time only moves
when you move allowing us to survey our
attackers and plan the perfect way to
take them all down without being shot
and should we be shot the entire Scene
resets It honestly feels like a training
scene from The Matrix with a long red
line depicting bullet velocity as you
slowly wander around this before the
action kicks in super hot demands
accurate shooting in the later stages
and using inanimate objects to your
advantage the end of the game is pretty
tricky too but that's a conversation for
another time right now you just need to
decide if you're gonna try it so what do
you think happy sad delighted mad sound
off in the comments below I'm Adam I'm
definitely gonna play Hot Wheels
Unleashed it's been a pleasure I'll see
you next time
[Music]